well having convinced poor Jeff Flake to
order a week-long FBI investigation of
judge Brett Kavanaugh that happened
after someone screamed at him in an
elevator which is how our democracy
works now Democrats are now trying to
dictate the scope of the investigation
as if they're in charge of Congress
which thanks to Jeff Flake functionally
they are in a letter released today ten
Democrats of the Senate Judiciary
Committee have called for the bureau to
investigate all three allegations
against Cavanaugh including Julie sweat
Knicks fantasy about gang rape their
letter also lists 24 people they would
like interviewed at a bare minimum about
their allegations Jonathan Turley his
professor Georgetown University Law
School and he joins us tonight professor
thanks for coming on so it are we right
to feel a little bit misled when
Democrats in public told us just on
Friday it's not mondays with three days
later that they wanted just Christine
Ford's allegations investigated for a
week and now the goal posts are so far
down the field we can't see them should
we feel like we've been lied to
well I think that the least convincing
part of the Democratic case is that this
was not being manipulated in terms of
its timing I think most people believe
that this these allegations were held to
the last minute right before a vote and
I think there's some legitimate
criticism for that and also I think you
one can anticipate that one week is not
going to satisfy many of the critics the
fact is that that most of these
statements if not all of them were
previously given to the committee
they're unlikely to change and so the
outcome of this investigation is
unlikely to change many minds and we're
going to get to a point where we have to
make a decision if senators feel that
the record is insufficient they have a
reason I suppose to vote on that basis
but to keep this open indefinitely is
going to do I think an injustice to the
nominee into the process so we have to
come to some conclusion so Julie sweat
Nick's claims that there was a series of
at least 10 gang rapes that took place
in public of children sometime in the
early 1980s outside Washington no one's
ever heard this before it's never been
alleged before do you think this rises
to the level of credibility that would
spur an FB
investigation almost 40 years later it
sounds like the FBI is not going to
investigate that allegation part of the
concern for many people is that this is
an extraordinary allegation with with it
and no one going to the police and
previously or any accounts being
published as to what occurred and is for
that reason I think that the FBI is
focusing on the other or the earlier two
allegations huh do you expect that
Republicans will be able to reassert
control over this process since I think
they do run the United States Senate
could they say you know it's been enough
time we you know it's been mark judge
has been interviewed again under oath
and we're done can they do that of
course I can and it does appear that
McConnell is going to push this through
he insists that is here be a vote this
week the timing is a little bit curious
because the FBI was given a full week
that would end on Friday presumably a
lot of material would be given to the
Senate on Friday so it's not quite clear
how the logistics are going to happen
for the FBI to be concluded on Friday
presumably and also have the vote on
Friday okay professor Shirley thanks
very much it's great job Thank You
Tucker